bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france le liban était déjà
dans une situation économique très
difficile la crise sanitaire accentue
ses difficultés ces dernières semaines
on l'a vu dans les bureaux de changes la
livre libanaise a poursuivi sa
dégringolade
très généralement comment est-ce que
tout cela se traduit-il pour les
entreprises libanaises
regardez comme vous avez dit dans le
reportage ci bien le liban passe par une
des périodes les plus difficiles de son
de son histoire je dirais même bien
avant les années 80 j'irais même jusqu'à
la première guerre mondiale aux niveaux
politique au niveau économique au niveau
sécuritaire au niveau monétaire
c'est vrai qu'on voit mais je vais dire
entre guillemets une descente aux enfers
qui a commencé bien avant le coc vide en
tout cas quand en tout cas on a assisté
au 17 octobre 2019 à la nouvelle
révolution libanaises pour une grande
dégradation du pouvoir d'achat libanais
et un 2-1 demandes de changement
politique et ensuite cette descente aux
enfers c'était ses comptes signés avec
l'arrivée du coc vide
et finalement comme vous l'avez aussi
dit dans votre reportage le 7 mars 2020
quand le premier ministre a annoncé le
défaut de paiement pour la première fois
dans l'histoire libanaise donc
aujourd'hui je commence par la
population comme la banque mondiale a
dit puisque 50% à notre population vit
sous le seuil de pauvreté dont 22 % sous
le seuil extrême de la pauvreté les
entreprises ibanez son rang grand
problème parce qu'il faut bien savoir
qu'on a un gros problème de liquidités
il faut savoir que finalement nous
importons 80 % de nos besoins et on
avait un bourrin manque de liquidités en
devise étrangère pouvoir acheter de nos
fournisseurs 12 européens ou autres
et aujourd'hui ce que nous vivons c'est
que chaque jour là des nouvelles
nouvelles avec la dégringolade de la
livre
la description du pouvoir d'achat et une
crise sociale jamais vu comme on voit
aujourd'hui dans les corps la banque
centrale injustement est
particulièrement critiquée pour avoir
été incapable d'enrayer une forte
dépréciation d'un livre
libanaise son chef rejette la faute sur
le gouvernement qui selon lui n'a pas
adopté les réformes qui étaient promises
qui aurait aggravé selon lui la crise
est ce que c'est aussi votre sentiment
écoutez la banque centrale finalement
joue le rôle de régulateur une banque
centrale s'est elle à financer l'état
mais c'est pas la banque centrale qui a
dépensé l'argent il faut dire que ça
fait plus que trente ans que notre pays
et notre gouvernement vient d city site
de plus de trois à six milliards par an
je pense que l'on compte faire la banque
centrale a repoussé cette chute depuis
depuis des années et il faut dire
qu'aujourd'hui elle n'a plus pu financer
ni le peg sur la livre libanaise ni pu
suivre
si on veut revenir un peu en arrière en
arrière on a les deux gros problème que
le liban vit aujourd'hui c'est une perte
de confiance totale
une perte de confiance entre le peuple
et l'état une perte de confiance entre
nos expatriés libanais qui contribua à
plus de 15 à 17% du pib avec le pays
parce que leur argent a été bloqué pour
ne pas dire confisqués au liban est une
terre de confiance de la communauté
internationale avec l'état et à dire que
la communauté internationale à financer
longtemps ce déficit donc aujourd'hui
tout notre système libanais notre
système économique s'écroule
il faut dire que le même système il dit
qu'aujourd'hui on may not par jean
banques on a des intérêts la banque
centrale finance un état qui est
déficitaire ne peut plus marcher c'est
très clair que la seule solution
aujourd'hui il peut être fait c'est un
appel officiel au fonds monétaire
international
mais qui va venir avec des conditions
très difficiles et c'est là la question
il faut déjà présenté un plan unique ce
qui n'est pas encore le cas et il faut
accepter les conditions qui vont nous
être contraint du fonds monétaire le
gouvernement libanais planche sur un
plan de relance économique
ils devraient être finalisées ces
prochaines heures quelle mesure est ce
que vous attendez comment selon vous est
ce qu'il faut est ce qu'on peut relancer
l'économie au liban regardez la première
chose pour répondre sur votre question
le plan économique et proposé doit voir
va faire le parcours du combattant ce
plan économique doit d'abord avoir
l'accord du gouvernement libanais céda 1
ce qui n'est pas dit ensuite il doit
passer au parlement
et est ce que ce parlement va accepter
ce plan comme il est dit de la même
façon parce qu'il ya beaucoup de buzz ne
peux plus je dirais le démon et entre
les détails l'histoire de terre pâtes et
autres donc avoir le plus important
c'est qu'ils aient un plan commun et
s'il n'y a pas un
plan qu'on a c'est impossible pouvoir
implémenter et ensuite c'est aller à la
banque mondiale et au fonds monétaire
dit voilà il ya un plan qui a l'accord
de toutes les parties politiques et
c'est là la grande question si tous les
partis politiques dont vont l'appuyer
donc ça c'est la première question quand
vous avez dit comment on peut relancer
le liban le premier problème j'ai bien
dit que c'était le problème de confiance
et remettent la confiance n'est pas
facile tu mets le deuxième problème est
aussi crucial c'est le manque de
liquidités comme vous voyez le liban est
un pays où ils travaillent sur des
liquidités en euros et en dollars et on
a un grand manque de liquidités le seul
moyen de relancer l'économie c'est
injecter de nouvelles liquidités et on
parle environs de 20 à 30 milliards à ce
n'est plus des pique niques unités de
paris 1 paris 2 ou paris iii fait des
injections de fonds b une injection de
fonds qui doit venir avec une réforme
totale du système
d'autre part le liban est un pays
peut-être en faillite mais c'est un pays
riche il faut dire que l'état a encore
tous ces terrains on parle d'un milliard
de mecs père et à l'état toutes les
institutions de l'état qui se sont les
télécoms les téléphones low l'aéroport
le port appartiennent à l'état on peut
même rentré aujourd'hui sur un projet de
privatisation que nous secteur privé on
demande depuis longtemps mais vous faire
très attention c'est une privatisation
qui doit pas être à des prix très bas
ça c'est le premier point et de deux on
veut surtout par vers le modèle le
modèle russe ou le modèle égyptien où ce
sont les pas l'argent de la corruption
qui revenue au liban pour acheter ou
brader les prix donc aujourd'hui oui il
ya des solutions injection de fonds de
fonds monétaire international et iii une
privatisation bien organisée et bien
suivi avec des sociétés d'audit et un
support international
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre à nos questions fouad zmokhol
je rappelle que vous êtes président des
dirigeants et chefs d'entreprise et
berné dans le monde